>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Joan Weeks: Well, good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen,
and welcome to the African
and Middle East Division
of The Library of Congress.
Today's lecture on
Analysis and Curation
of the American Traveler's
Visual Documents of 1870 to 1936
on Central Asian Nomadic Culture
by Saule Satayeva is brought to you
and sponsored by the
Near East Section
of the African Middle East Division.
I'm Joan Weeks, Head of
the Near East Section.
And on behalf of all my colleagues
in particular Dr. Mary Jane Deeb
[assumed spelling] who couldn't be
with us today due to
a conflicting program,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
And before we start
today's program I'd
like to give you a brief overview
of the division and its resources
in the hopes that you'll come again
and use our collections
for your research.
This division, as many of you
know that have attended a lot
of these programs, is
comprised of three sections
that serve the collections to
researchers from around the world.
We cover 78 countries and
more than 35 languages.
The African Section includes
all of sub-Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic Section is responsible
for Judaica and Hebraic worldwide.
And the Near East Section covers all
of the Arab countries including
North Africa, Turkey, Iran,
Afghanistan, Central Asia,
the Muslims of Western China,
Russia and the Balkans as well
as the People of the Caucuses.
So we really cover an extensive area
with our collections
and our programs.
Just a couple housekeeping
things first.
After the program we invite you
to fill in the evaluation forms
that we placed on your seats.
And please leave them in the box
at the information
desk as you're leaving.
Secondly, we would like to invite
you to ask questions at the end.
But just remind you that
you're being videotaped so that
if you do ask questions you are
giving us permission to be recorded.
Now, I'd like to introduce
our speaker.
Soule Satayeva is Vice-Director of
the Kazakh Central State Archive
of Cinema, Photo and Recording
Documents in Astana, Kazakhstan,
a position she's held since 2010.
Saule was born into a family of a
famous Kazakh writer, play writer,
archivist, Amante Satayeva, and grew
up among old manuscripts
and photographs.
And you could see how now this
has influenced her life career
and passion.
Her father's dream was for her to
graduate with a scientific degree
and become a Fulbright Scholar.
Quite an ambitious
dream for your daughter.
Well, she did graduate with
a degree in engineering
from Almaty Technical University
and was a Fulbright Scholar
at American University here in
Washington from 2012 to 2013,
where she did archival
research relating
to illuminating the
Kazakh nomadic culture.
She is a member of the
Kazakh Society of Archivists.
Today's program draws
upon her archival research
of the American Travels who
illuminated Kazakh nomadic culture
through their visual documents.
And please give me a warm welcome
to invite Saule to the podium
to show us all of her
photographic collection.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Saule Satayeva: Thank you so
much for so warm introducing.
I am very happy to be in this
great country and great library.
And let me start my talk.
It is recognized today
that the latest stage
of our global consumer culture
have created a new crisis.
And many scholars now are looking
for the ways and discuss the futures
of a new ideology that will prolong
the existence of human beings
by reducing competition
for land, water and food
and by preserving natural resources.
And scholars now realize the
correlations between this ideology
and ideology of nomadic cultures.
And they explore the way in which
this ancient culture can inform our
lifestyles in the future.
And this project represents that
outgrowth my dissertation based
on a comparative analysis of visual
documents and writing sources.
And also, I have been
studying this project,
the subject of nomadic culture and
visual documents for many years.
And since I have made
research in Kazakh libraries
where I was fortunate to
uncover several printed works
of foreign travelers to Asia
and also a bibliographical edition
listing travelers to Central Asia.
And the second was my Fulbright
Scholarship where I was fortunate
to uncover visual documents
of American travelers
to Kazakhstan while presenting
lecture at Harvard, Columbia,
Wisconsin Medicine, Indiana, Texas
and Maryland universities as well
as at Wilson Center,
Smithsonian Institution
and American University
in Washington, DC.
But it was one of your
best librarians,
Harold Leich who I contacted
when I just have a dream
to come here as a Fulbright Scholar.
It was early two millennium.
And I got his very warm invitation
to come sometimes and to do research
at the Library of Congress.
And when I came here Harold
Leich and Patrick Longhney,
they gave me a tour to Packard
Campus, which was a huge collection
of audio-visual documents
from all over the world.
And you can see here where
Patrick opened me a door
to explore the treasures
of the Library of Congress.
And I'm very grateful for the
library and for my colleagues.
And also, I hope to
contact a new audience here
in DC now during my
very short stay here.
Because it is the ninth
largest country in the world.
And it is strategically vital region
in Eurasia as well as very peaceful
and reliable country
in Central Asia.
And Americans, in my experience,
know very little about Kazakhstan.
And this is the map of my country.
And you can see in
the center Astana.
My archive and I live in Almaty,
which is -- I cannot show it.
Which is -- Almaty, on
the border with Kurdistan.
And you can see, we are situated
between two huge empires,
the Russian Federation and China.
And also Central Asian Republics.
In our country we have
everything except ocean.
To see Caspian and Aral Sea, a lot
of rivers, beautiful mountains.
We have a western range
of Tien-Shan mountains.
We have steppe, lakes,
desert, semi-desert.
Everything.
And we have very beautiful nature.
And also, that I would like to
show the pictures of my father,
who was a student at the Moscow
Historical Archival University
in late 1940s.
And exactly at that time he
started American traveler's diaries
at the Lenin Library.
So he kept these notes until I
grow up and make me interesting.
He made me interesting in
this very interesting subject.
And he also was the author of a
number of documental movies related
to the history of Kazakhstan.
And today my talk would be
focused on three questions.
Why the history and culture of
nomads must be started today.
And about the exceptionality
of the Kazakh nomadic culture.
And about Americans who contributed
in preserving our nomadic history.
The understanding how human
nowadays shaped the planet shows us
that nomadic economy now
exists in almost 30 countries,
nvolving in total about
40 million people.
And nomads in China and Mongolia.
Nomads in Siberia.
In South Africa and
in North America.
They live desert, semi-desert,
tundra and steppe
where agriculture is impossible.
And in the 21st Century Mongols
and Kazakh who historically lived
on that territory as the
so-called iridienta [phonetic].
And some tribes migrated trying
to escape the Soviet policy.
They well adapted to
a modernizing world.
And their tradition and isolation
helped preserve their lifestyle.
They use achievements
of civilization.
They not prevent them from migrating
while maintaining their ancestor's
heritage, including principles
of sufficient consumption
and also genetic health.
Nomadic society has
been transforming.
However, in psychology
and life attitudes traces
of nomadic culture habits
have been preserved.
If over time reminiscences
of nomadism will be
a thing of the past.
Today there is less
time for construction
of this very unique culture.
With the example of Kazakhs,
it is known that the
longest preserved elements
of sacred property, even
with the full replacement
of traditional livelihood
systems by innovations.
And also, in the modern educational
system, the young generation is used
to get very fast and
visual information.
And we have to help them to urge
a deeper interest in cultural
and artistic disciplines.
And there is a task to
educate tolerant people
which would be interesting to
create conditions for identification
with native culture and exploration
of the variety of cultures, beliefs
and social political systems.
About exceptionality of
Kazakh nomadic culture.
The Kazakh have been the
object of Western research
in Oriental studies, cultural
studies, linguistic, anthropology,
archeology, historical geography
because their territory included
in the vast steppe empires such as
[inaudible], Huns, Turkik Empire,
Western and Eastern Kipchaks,
Timurids and Mongol Empire.
And also the Kazakh
language consists of two
and a half million words.
And it is very valuable source.
Also, the Kazakh ancestors'
brilliant epic oral tradition was
continued in the Kazakh culture.
And another point is that the
Kazakhs ethnically emerged
from a union of different nations.
And the uniqueness of their
nomadic culture is a combination
of steppe and town.
A major characteristic of
the Kazakh nomadic culture
that in difficult climatic
conditions the people kept a harmony
with nature and created a symbiosis
between urban and rural
environments.
In the nomad society,
however, existed the contempt
of agriculture employment,
which they view as [inaudible].
In their mind an inability to
migrate and lack of cattle,
considered almost a
humiliation and shame.
And in 1897 the general
population survey data
of the Russian Empire
indicates that 80%
of 6 million Kazakhs' livelihood
stemmed from pastoral products
and 18 came specifically from both
integrated cattle and farming only
in natural irrigated areas.
The Kazakh migrated up
to 120 times a year.
So some clans had normal
to [inaudible]
to migrate along the
natural water sources.
And some, they had to migrate
along the artificial water sources
and draw wells.
And it was settlers in ancient time
during -- the Kazakhan [phonetic],
it was organized in
the early 15th Century.
So it was settled by Kazakh Khans.
Which clan have this
certain way of migration.
And in addition, the Kazakhs,
because they draw wells
and archeological finds of
how they watered the cattle.
In addition, the Kazakhs were
engaged in fishing and hunting.
The Kazakhs hunted with falcon.
And also, they had a special breed
of hunting horses named [inaudible].
And also they hunted
with the golden eagle.
And also, in a variety
of arts and crafts.
Because the Kazakh had this
nomad way of life and they had
to migrate many times a
year, they couldn't keep
with themselves decorations,
special decorations.
So they make every piece, every
bedding, furniture, dishes,
cupboards, they made
it as a piece of art.
And they also used other things.
And this thing they passed
from generation to generation.
In springtime they left winter
[inaudible] for meadows.
And the camels and horses and sheep
grazed freely in the vast area.
And this [inaudible]
nomadic modification lasted
until the early 1940s.
And for such sanctuaries Kazakhs
absorbed cultural influences
assimilating some of them.
Mongol, Islamic and Russian
influence did not change
them radically.
They demonstrated their adaptability
under the constantly
changing environment.
Because Kazakhstan was
always on the crossroad
of different cultures
from West and East.
And it was the Silk Way.
And through Kazakhstan [inaudible]
through Almaty there were
several ways to get from Europe
to China, India or Mongolia.
And the extinction of Kazakh
nomadic culture was [inaudible]
by the colonization
policy of Russian Empire.
Civil war, Russian Revolution
and followed civil war
and Soviet agricultural policy
that brought to the great famine
in the 1930s and migration
to neighborhood countries,
thousand hundreds of Kazakh nomads.
And also, another huge impact
was the Stalin oppression regime
against the so-called
people's enemies.
When almost all our
intelligent, progressive
and well-educated personalities were
killed as the peoples of enemies.
Collectivization and [inaudible]
in the 1928 caused a wave
of huge uprising in the entire
country, in the entire Soviet Union.
But in Kazakhstan they
were most widespread
because they have not been yet
destroyed traditional clan system.
According to archival documents
from 1928 till 1933 there were
over 400 uprisings and riots.
But the rebel sources with their
limited arms couldn't be compared
with the well-trained Red Army
units and [inaudible] divisions.
And one of the Soviet
power achievements was
that it's totally changed
the face of the society,
especially the young
generation psychology.
That all the authority's action
to suppress people's
enemies were supported,
silently supported,
in the community.
And the origin of Stalin's struggle
with nationalism can be found
in his total rejection of our
intelligent people's strive
for independence, which
he considered as, again,
taking too seriously by our
advanced and well-educated people.
The Communist Party needed
money to convert the country
from agricultural into industrial.
Therefore, they needed
rich people properties.
In the minds of Stalin and
Galashurkin [phonetic] the ruler
of Kazakhstan, the
Kazakhs were a rich nation.
Because less than 5 million people,
they had 40 million head of stock.
And starting from 1928 they erected
several factories to produce meat
and sell it to the
Western countries.
And also sell a lot of
wheat to Western countries.
And from 40 million head of stock
in the 1933 left only 4 million.
And analysis of our historians
and demographers shows
that my people lost
2.2 million people.
And that was 49% of the
population at that time.
And 600,000 Kazakh migrated
to neighborhood countries.
And that was the end of
Kazakh nomadic culture.
The problem of the Kazakh famine
and nomadic cultural research
should be studied for the sake
of historical truth and justice.
And also in order to
prevent repetition
of similar tragedies in the future.
And my work and research will
have further understanding
of Kazakh culture and how it relates
to other unique nomadic cultures.
Philosophers and culturalists know
that the more [inaudible]
the world unites,
the more actively people connect
to protect their national identity.
And believe that in order to
survive in the global world,
they should change in
their cultural roots.
And this has brought
[inaudible] processes
of [inaudible] dialectic
of globalization law.
And we have a general
crisis of values now.
Because the manufacture of human
happiness has become the central
problem of new technological age.
There are free will, but to
change this is impossible
without changing the
individual's relation to the world.
And we need the more highest and
more reliable reference points.
When I did research in the Kazakh
library of Academy of Science,
I have found the printed manuscript
of Armeni Vanbili [assumed
spelling], the Hungarian traveler,
who in the 1880s as a
pilgrim, he made journey --
he was Turkologist linguist.
He made journey from
Hungary to East, to Asia.
And he wrote that he had to
sleep with only one closed
because he was afraid
that when he would speak
in his native language
in his dreams.
So at that time, for foreign people
from Europe, it was very dangerous
to do such kind of trips.
And he wrote in that book
that he met one Kazakh woman.
And he asked her about the
reasons inducing them to migrate.
And she answered him with laughter.
"We are not so lazy as
you are [inaudible].
We cannot sit on one
place whole days.
You see, the men should move
because the moon, star, sun, water,
animals, birds, fish all move.
Only ground and dead
remain on the place."
And two years ago I was
on conference in Moscow.
And I realized my long plan to
visit the Museum of Nomadic Culture
in Moscow and meet the director of
that museum, Constantine Kuksin,
which I knew by his
publication before.
And Constantine Kuksin, he
travels all over the world.
And he has a number of dwelling
houses of different nomadic people.
And it's very nice museum.
This is Kazakh yurt.
He collected all that material.
And he said that if you want
to study Kazakh nomadic culture
you should go to Mongolia.
So, that is his citation
from his article.
And I'm totally agree that
"nomadic people with their way
of life are not an echo
of bygone centuries.
They live in the 21 Century among us
and keep their modest
life despite the fact
that many great empires collapsed,
leaving us with only
records and monuments.
Because they took just like that,
not giving anything in return.
In fact, nobody knows where is
going the Western civilization.
And if the world will suffer from
a catastrophe, it's more likely
that only nomads will survive."
That's why decided that
nomads are very strong reserve
of human civilization.
So, I came to my last
part of my talk.
And I'm very happy to say, to
speak, to talk about brave, curious,
intelligent, well-educated American
travelers who did not afraid to go
to the land of terra incognita
in the late 19th Century,
beginning of 20th.
And the reconstruction
of [inaudible] picture
of the past demands the
examination of new sources
which offer us the possibility to
expand our past representations.
And the study of nomadic culture
is impossible without bringing
in writing and visual
documents created
by participants or
direct eyewitnesses.
So, there is all foreign
travelers, scholars, diplomats,
merchants falls into that category.
And they have great value because
they brightly express the color
of the epoch and give certain
information or historiography,
economic employments, way of
life, traditions and customs.
And that is the information how
man study man in all variety
of [inaudible] his display.
And also, audiovisual documents.
This is George Kennan, one of the
famous journalists and traveler.
In 1885 he researched the life of
peoples of Siberia and Kazakhstan.
And from the American
biographic sources follows
that he was typical self-made man.
In 1855 at orders of "Century
Illustrated" monthly magazine
together with the artist George
Frost, he studied exiled places
of political prisoners
of imperial Russia,
located on the [inaudible]
of Kazakhstan.
The Imperial administration
[inaudible] was exiling unreliable
people, carried out the policy
of colonization of Kazakhstan.
And travelers were occupied
with bulky photographic devices.
And George Frost did it numerous
drawings and photographs.
And this is a marketplace
in Semipalatinsk.
This is one of the biggest
our city in Kazakhstan.
Kazakh nomadic they documented also.
Semipalatinsk we have a very big
Irtysh River and ferry on it.
In his archive there are a lot
of photographs of exiled people.
And very interesting photographs
when Kazakhs had a meeting
with official general
government in Semipalatinsk.
And also they documented some
nature, the Kazakh steppe in spring.
So, you can see that a witness of
this visual documents, photographs,
cinema documents, they can
offer previously unknown facts
or already forgotten facts,
which is sometimes the same.
And or important data to triangulate
with already known events.
And they fix information
that cannot be reflected
in other kind of sources.
Eugene Schuyler, he
was consul at Moscow
and St. Petersburg in 1870, 1876.
And he was familiar with the
very well-known Russian writers,
scholars, military men.
And he was very well, in good
relations with Leo Tolstoy.
And Leo Tolstoy, he advised him
to go to Arinbourg [phonetic]
which used to be the capital
of Kazakhaned [phonetic]
which is up of the Caspian Sea.
And he advised him
to go to the east.
And supplied him with
letters and recommendations
to his friends and relatives.
So, Schuyler traveled
by train to Arinbourg.
And from Arinbourg he traveled
along Caspian Sea, Aral Sea
and also the cities that
placed in that area.
Later he appeared with the reports
about his trips at the session
of Russian Geographic Society
and became its full member.
And also, he met the son of the
last khan of the [inaudible] horde,
Gubaydolla Zhangirov, who
introduces Schuyler to the history
of the Mausoleum Hodzha Akhmet
Yassayi and its unique exhibits.
And he wrote: "Almost
our only fellow passenger
in the carriage was Prince
Tchinghiz, a lineal descendant
of famous Tchinghiz Khan,
and the son of the last Khan
of the Bukeief Horde of Kirghiz.
Strange that that on the threshold
of Asia I should meet the descendant
of its greatest conqueror.
After the death of his
father, he, the eldest son,
was given the Russian
title of Prince in memory
of his ancient lineage, and of
the services of his father."
Really, Gubaydolla Zhangirov
was a very interesting
and outstanding companion
of American diplomat.
He left from [inaudible] of pages in
St. Petersburg and for participation
in Russian-Turkish war in 1877 he
received the rank of general major.
Schuyler characterized him
as a cultural diplomat,
deeply knowing French literature.
And he helped Eugene Schuyler
to visit Mausoleum
Hodzha Akhmet Yassayi.
And later Schuyler wrote
about this majestic structure.
He was there at the restless time.
Mausoleum was in the center
of events when Imperial Army
of Russia started its
military expansion
against Central Asian Khans,
[inaudible] and [inaudible].
Today the information written by
the American diplomat, interesting,
first because his own
vision of the Mausoleum.
And second, at that time, the
Mausoleum was used as an armory.
And all the gravestones and
monuments were taken out.
And Schuyler's records
provide some information
about where exactly Kazakh Khans and
their descendants have be buried.
And the fact that the
Imperial conquerors intended
to destroy this unique
structure is well known.
And all the intervention
of the advanced democratic
people opinion rescued it
from the destruction.
And there is the pictures of the
nowadays mausoleum, which is --
it is very unique structure
in Central Asia.
It is one of the biggest.
And there is some elements
of the mausoleum.
And it's very crowded for
tourists and also for people
who follow Islam in Central Asia.
And also, it's interesting how
Schuyler wrote about the area
where he visited: "The
whole area carries
on itself the traces
of ancient cultivation.
It is obvious there was
existed a vast settlement
of the people Here the hills
covered by brakes of haloxylon
and other bushes here
and there, apparently.
They are ruins of ancient
cities, evidently.
There exists an old legend that
all valley of Syr-Dar'ya was
so dense populated one time that
a nightingale flying from a branch
to branch of fruit trees, and a
cat running from a wall to wall
and from a roof to roof could reach
from the Kashgar up to the Aral.
By traces of this part of the river,
here there were large prospering
cities here, among which Otrar,
Sauran, Tend and Tani-Kend
were allocated."
And that's true.
Later Kazakhstan is
one of the unique place
where lived people
since ancient time.
And we have over 300 places
of ancient petroglyphs.
And also, our archeologists
discovered
over 150,000 settlements
only along Syr-Dar'ya River.
And also, a lot of towns were
discovered in the north, east,
west and center of Kazakhstan.
For example, this is a burial mound
of Skiffen [phonetic] culture,
which could be found from the
Pacific Ocean to the Black Sea.
[Inaudible] from the
Turkey [inaudible].
And also a number of mausoleums.
Another great American
traveler, Januarius MacGahan,
correspondent of "New York Herald."
He was another Schuyler's encounter.
In 1873 with extreme hardship he
reached the Russian army before
[inaudible] and sent to the
Herald reports of his companion,
which won him high admiration
both at home and in Europe.
His account of capitulation
of the city being regarded
as a masterpiece of
military journalism.
It is known that MacGahan gave
description of historical monuments,
music, culture, way
of life of Kazakhs.
And what is the more interesting
and unique for us that he wrote
about Kazakh national
instrument dombra,
which was popular and
now very popular.
And usually it has two strings.
But he wrote that this dombra
has third string made of copper.
And it's very rare musical
instruments and Kazakh used it
since ancient time
from AD centuries.
The famous American geologist
William Davis Morris visited our
southeast territory in 1913.
And he studied Tien-Shan Mountains
in connection to the global problem
of interrelation of nature.
Specifically he looked how
changing climatic condition
of Asia influenced the history of
people who lived in that territory.
And when I was presenting lecture
at Harvard University
I had only three days.
And that university has
a number of libraries.
So just on the last day, just
a few hours before my plane,
I found his diaries, named
"Turkistan 1" and Turkistan 2."
And I managed to make a
pictures from my cell phone.
And I was very happy.
And this album has a lot
of beautiful drawings.
And also some of the drawings
not only about his profession,
about geology and also
about our culture.
And that was very interesting
that I lived in Harvard.
And I had to go to Boston.
So I had to be in Boston as well.
So, I made a stop in Boston.
Went up from Metro.
Made pictures in four direction.
And now I can say that
I was in Boston as well.
But, it was just maybe one minute.
So, in that way I managed
to discover photographs
when I did my talks in
different universities.
So, one of the brightest collection
I discovered in the archive
of New York Natural History Museum.
In 1926 they sent expedition
to Asia.
The so-called Morden and
Clark Asiatic Expedition.
And in that expedition included a
lot of botanists, anthropologists,
zoologists, photographers.
And they documented everything they
saw including our flora and fauna
of the region they visited and also
way of life and economic employments
of the nations who lived in that
territory, including Kazakhs.
And this is screenshot
from the silent movie.
They provided me the
copy of the silent movie.
And you can see they
started from Bombay.
They crossed India.
They crossed Tibet.
Then they crossed China
and Kazakhstan.
And also the places
where lived Kyrgyz,
Oygurs [phonetic] and also Russia.
And in Biskh [phonetic]
they took train to Beijing.
So, it was a very long,
very interesting expedition.
And if we will have time,
I would like to show you a
little bit of this movie.
And later, William Morden, he
wrote this unique publication,
published this about their
life during this expedition.
On this picture you can see camels.
Camels are very important
animal for the caravan.
Only camel can see straight
to the face of the hurricane.
And he can bring you to the place
you need even no one can see
anything except snow and wind.
So it was very -- it is very
valuable, very reliable,
wise and stable cattle
in our culture.
Red Army soldiers, 1926.
Kazakh hunter.
In my last days of my Fulbright
Scholarship, all the 11 months
when I have been here, I tried
to see the collection
of National Geographic.
But I was denied because they
said that their archive are not
for the international researchers.
So, but we lived here.
We made a lot of friends
and colleagues.
And one of my friend,
who adopted Kazakh boy,
his brother's wife worked for
that National Geographic Society.
So again, in the last days
of my stay here I was allowed
to see archives of
National Geographic Society.
And they said: You
have only one hour.
So I had to be very fast.
And I made pictures
of their archive.
And it was amazing because in 1936
there was a sun icplease [phonetic].
Icplease?
>> Eclipse.
>> Saule Satayeva: Eclipse.
Sun eclipse.
And in the entire Soviet Union
there were about 40 expeditions,
including Soviet expeditions.
And American Bureau
of Standards as well.
So they were in Kazakhstan
in our [inaudible] city
and Abulak [phonetic] village.
And they documented this
very rare astronomical event
on the June 19, 1936.
And at that time they [inaudible]
from the Black Sea to Kamchatka.
And among them were photographers.
Irving Gardner, Paul
McNealy and Robert Moore.
And they documented also the life
of ordinary citizens
and the Kazakh people.
And why they're available?
Because that is unique visual
information about Kazakhs
that survived after the great
famine in 1933 -- 1931, 1933.
So the English proverb says
that [inaudible] see the
most of the [inaudible].
And I believe that
American travelers document,
visual documents, [inaudible]
a lot of [inaudible]
that should be discovered.
And it is especially
important to know
that Americans travels photographs
have not been yet the subject
of a special study in the history
to study the nomadic culture.
In travels, a personal photographs,
they are obviously less official,
less political than
official publications.
In the ancient nomadic tradition,
material culture are less present
in material data because
felt, leather
or wood are not easily preserved.
And it is hard to imagine,
original text hard
to imagine how nomads
dressed, looked like and lived.
And also, one of the obstacles of
Kazakh historiography is the lack --
or is not relatively not big amount
of writing and visual documents.
And most documents were made
by neighborhood countries.
And because of political influence,
they are not full and objective.
And for the long time the Kazakhs
in Russian historiography were
called Kyrgyz, which was a mistake.
And also, it's very difficult
for researchers to study,
to identify which belong
to Kyrgyz culture nomadic
or to Kazakh culture.
And thanks to the Library
of Congress
that accumulated a huge amount
of documents, visual and writing.
And our task is to find the most
appropriate usage of this heritage.
And I have applied for the
Library of Congress Scholarship,
the Kluge Scholarship with the
idea to create digital album
about named American
travelers to Central Asia
with their portraits, photographs.
They made drawings.
And also concise and
to the point citation
from their writing documents.
These two documents
would support another.
And for us archivists and scholars,
it's very important to find
as much documents as
possible and to enter them
into scholarly circulation.
And help the other researchers
to write their works based
on comparative analysis of
writing and visual documents.
And only that archival documents
that enter into the circulation
and published can pass the
stage of unit of storage
into the historical source.
So I'm very grateful for the
Library of Congress for this chance
to talk to this audience.
And even to the global audience
that will see my presentation.
And also very grateful that American
travelers also made me travel.
And very skilled traveler.
Very fast traveler.
So, thank you so much
for your attention.
And this is the end of my talk.
And I would be happy to
answer to your questions.
Ah!
[ Applause ]
Would you like to see a short?
>> Yes.
>> Let's see the [inaudible] film.
>> Saule Satayeva: Now,
just this [inaudible].
It's silent.
William Morden.
James Clark.
[Inaudible] that he saw
that one family with camels,
sheeps and horses came to stay on
one place that was in 45 minutes
that house was already finished.
Cattle was grazing nearby.
Fire was on and food
already prepared.
Because every member of the
family, they worked as a team.
Very fast.
So, also, I would like to
present this archival journal
to the library with
my article in it.
And also with a lot of articles
of our archivists and scholars.
This is one of the famous
archival journal in Kazakhstan.
And it would be a great honor for
us to have it in your library.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Thank
you so much for this
and for this brilliant presentation.
It's been fantastic.
I think we've all seen new things
that we would never
have seen before.
And I certainly am going to try
to a better job of traveling
and documenting as a result.
We do have a few minutes
for a couple questions,
if someone wanted ask them.
Somebody have a question.Yes.
>> This is about your
father's films.
You said he made documentary films.
>> Saule Satayeva: Yes.
>> Are they available somewhere?
>> Saule Satayeva: Yes,
they are available.
>> Joan Weeks: Repeat the
question for the audience.
>> Saule Satayeva: Ah.
About my father, who was the author
of several documental movies
relating to the history
and culture of Kazakh people.
They are available, yes.
They're available.
They are in our archive.
Because my archive is a cinema,
photo and sound recording documents.
And also they are available
in our Kazakh film studio.
>> Can you upload them, maybe
to YouTube or something?
>> Saule Satayeva: Yes.
I will try to do this.
Definitely.
Thank you.
>> Joan Weeks: Yes.
>> Thank you for the wonderful,
really interesting talk.
You could see, I was
writing lots of notes
because I'm very interested
in this topic.
I have, well, two brief questions.
One is just a thought.
Have you looked at the
writings of Langston Hughes?
Because he went to Central Asia,
I think mostly to Uzbekistan,
but I think he might
have gone to Kazakhstan.
And I'm curious.
This was also in the 1920s.
I wonder if he took
any photo [inaudible].
We could talk afterwards.
But I think he might have taken --
maybe he took some
photos of Kazakhs.
So that could be another American
to add to your collection.
>> Saule Satayeva: Yes, exactly.
>> And then, the second question
is, I'm wondering sometimes,
and this is my own curiosity,
because I find it very
difficult, you know.
As you mentioned, there
was this confusion
about what Kazakhs should be called.
Whether they should
be called Kyrgyz.
Whether they should be
called this other name.
And sometimes also
people on the ground,
especially these American travelers,
didn't understand maybe
who they were meeting.
Whether it was a Kazakh
or Kyrgyz or so on.
And I imagine that's
particularly difficult in the film
versus when they go through
many different places.
And I'm wondering how you tell.
How do you tell if [inaudible]
when you're using these images?
How do you tell, you
know, what group it is?
>> Saule Satayeva: Mm-hmm.
So, about the first question about
American traveler Langston Hughes.
I didn't heard about him.
>> I'll tell you about him.
>> Saule Satayeva: That would
be great because I always
like to add traveler to my list.
And about second question about
this very huge obstacle that we are
in Russian historiography
we're all called Kyrgyz.
Yes. And this is quite
easy if I do research
about travelers who did in Siberia.
So in Siberia there were no Kyrgyz.
They were Kazakhs.
And it's quite difficult
if it's Turkistan area.
So, the way I can tell is
that in that movie especially,
the Kyrgyz were first, after Tibet.
Kyrgyz were first.
And they used in their
nomadic economy yaks.
And after that, we are.
So, that's why I --
because it's chronological.
They went up through -- so
Kyrgyz were on that side of --
south side of Tien-Shan Mountains.
And we are on the north side.
So it's only chronological.
And also, of course, our
specialist can see the --
the yurt, especially,
dwelling house.
It's similar at first sight.
But it has some differences.
And our specialists
can differ, can differ.
And also by style of
dress, by animal they used.
So there's some hinges
that scholars can use.
But it is, of course,
it would be easy
if we were Kazakhs
everywhere in many sources.
So that was unfortunate for us.
So, thank you for that question.
>> Joan Weeks: Just
one more question?
Okay. Well, thank you so much
for this wonderful
addition to the collections.
Let's give another
round of applause.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.